i think actually the vast majority of
people
are going to follow what the nhs
asks them to do in these circumstances
because it's not only good for them
it's also good for their community it
helps us all
to keep the r down the whole point of
this new system
is to have a much more targeted approach
uh
so that we can hold the r down and
get trace those new uh
new cases and then break the train of
cat transmission
well there are powers that we took
through parliament at the start of the
crisis in the coronavirus act to be able
to
mandate this but of course all these
things are a new
and are a challenge but it'd be far
better if we didn't have to make it
mandatory so
that's why one of the reasons that we've
started with it on a voluntary basis
um well i say voluntary as in it's an
instruction from the nhs
and it's very important that you do it
but it's legally
not mandated at this stage because we
think it's far better
far far better if as a country we pull
together and do this and everybody
follows the instruction i need to focus
for this next bit
initially remember the government had
said a new nhs tracing app would form an
integral part of the test and trace
system remember but that's been delayed
until mid-june
so questions are being asked as to why
the contact traces are being rolled out
now instead of in line with the app
that's not yet ready
problem is you've rushed it forward
haven't you because you want to take the
headlines away from dominic cummings so
you brought it forward it should have
been
first of june when the app is being
launched at the same time then with the
app what you could have done is if
people go out they have to
uh have a gps on their phone and um they
have they get a call
or whatever a text every six or seven
hours like they do in singapore but
you've had to rush it forward
it's priceless okay i'm normally accused
of delaying these things and bringing
them in too slowly
we we it's i i i i committed to getting
the system in
in mid-may
you can't accuse me both
and we've still not got that app you
said the app
was absolutely essential to this track
and trace
you the app is still not ready until
next week
at the earliest maybe after that and yet
you've brought this forward
um i suppose many of my viewers will
think it's not a laughing matter
yes well i i i can't quite work out
whether you're telling me that i've gone
too slow or too
fast i think we've got it just tell you
what i don't think my viewers know
i think they're as confused as i am
clarify it for us oh yeah
well we brought it in at just the right
speed and uh
the crucial thing with the app the app
is uh helpful
it's working on the isle of wight